Diffusion runs a large network at every
step, so generation is slow.
Neighboring steps repeat almost the same
computation.
Caching keeps those internal features and
skips recomputing them.
The question is how to skip safely.
The obvious trick is to reuse the last
feature, or extrapolate it.
Both assume it changes smoothly, so a
fitted curve should continue it.
But early on it moves a lot, and the
forecast drifts away.
A fixed rule guesses a shape that keeps
changing.
Watch the same feature over the whole
process.
Early on, noise is high and change is fast
and uneven.
In the middle, change becomes small and
smooth.
Near the end it barely moves: only details
are refined.
One trajectory, three behaviours.
Call them stages.
Why should one predictor handle all three?
A single predictor must compromise: a rule
for the noisy start fails later.
If stages differ, the predictor should
differ too.
LESA (Learnable Stage-Aware predictors)
gives each stage its own expert.
Each expert uses a history window that
fits its stage.
Zoom into one expert.
It receives cached features from recent
steps: the history.
A learned linear projection mixes that
history into a vector, z.
A KAN (Kolmogorov-Arnold Network) turns
timestep offsets into one number, alpha.
The prediction adds a correction to the
current feature, scaled by alpha.
Training has two steps.
First it learns from accurate features.
At inference, its inputs are partly its
own predictions.
If it never sees its own mistakes, small
errors build up.
So training feeds it its own predictions,
as at inference.
Put it back together.
One trajectory, divided into stages by
noise level.
Each stage has its own expert, predicting
the skipped features.
Stages, experts, predicted features: that
is how LESA accelerates diffusion.